one day also sugar bear like I'm saying
really maybe play
what aspired you to make this big life
change um first was like sugar bear you
know I mean like I wanted to show him
that you know I could actually worth it
but a sugar bear think of your of your
new weight I don't know and don't really
care he was kinda shocked bit understand
like hear what he has to say or what he
has to do what was the first time that
he saw you at the wedding and how was
that awkward and I told him that he made
me feel like honestly I was I said does
he know that he was kind of the the real
reason at first to why you did all these
surgeries yeah yeah though you should me
that I wasn't worth anything you know I
mean and I felt like you losing the
weight it made me feel empowered
honestly what's your relationship like
do you guys talk on the phone do you
ever see each other
I mean he is in the nude Ilana they
don't see it at all you don't call or
anything
I find that through this show we were
going to be able to see what he really
is which is who I say not bother your
material are you kind of happy though
anytime you see him and him and Jennifer
and and you have a few life oh yeah I've
seen either one of them it's worse in
real life than it is on the show uh-huh
yeah so in the show we've seen you
before your surgeries trying to get back
out there in the dating world how has
that been recently I gave it up gave it
up it isn't worth it there's troops in
douchebags you never know who's gonna
hear for you and and everything but now
I mean have you even thought about
dating since you've had all these
surgeries I don't like maybe I mean yeah
have Yashiro crying I feel like that
those guys won't marry me because I live
a certain way I'm old TV honestly has
been tough meeting men that are genuine
what do you think was the most difficult
was it losing all the weight physically
or was it all the mental challenges at
your arm your you have to go through
right now mental because I um
I'm doing like sugar beer and having to
also deal with people who are they gonna
like thank
[Music]